these French teenagers love their
smartphones but now they're getting some
extra thrills with the help of a virtual
reality headset but when Mendez comes
I'll is up yeah this jump on icy snow
and trees and people in front of us but
I can't see any of you once you've put
on the headset the adventure can begin a
ride on the roller coaster at europark
roost has turned into a fast-paced
journey to virtual worlds
me hey amok is the theme parks managing
director he's invested more than a
million euros to equip two of his roller
coasters with the technology instead of
building new roller coasters which can
cost 10 or more times that amount it's
now possible to add some virtual
excitement to existing ones at a
fraction of the cost the spines of this
close to our effect when that's the big
WOW effect and it works a lot of
visitors get off the ride and say mr.
mock you said there was no loop you lie
there was a loop I've taken people on it
two or three times until they finally
believed me apana behind the adventure
park is the mock rides company they
produce hardware such as roller coaster
rails and cars now virtual reality is
taking the business to a whole new level
the headset has a built-in smartphone
that's connected to a control box that
allows the film to synchronize perfectly
with the location of the car laying on a
lot on holcomb in the future visitors
will be able to interact with their
virtual reality ride icon ignition
cutoff talk afgan you'll be able to push
a button shoot it objects and be
rewarded with points so in the end you
might have a hundred thousand points and
in the future you'll see your hands in
the virtual reality world and be able to
touch objects and collect them and grab
them we're in conda's amin khan oregon a
large part of machs revenue comes from
roller coaster sales most of the Mercs
ported now the companies started to
update thousands of rides around the
world with the virtual reality
technology and 3d films virtual reality
has become a lucrative boost for fun
parks
you